ja meine verehrten damen und herren
gesetzte anwesenden pressevertreter
liebe weitere gäste liebe parteifreunde
in den tagen vor diesem bundesparteitag
habe ich in allerlei dingen ein déjà vu
erlebnis gehabt
wieder einmal schlagen die wellen in
unserer partei wieder einmal ist von
streit und zerwürfnisse die rede
wieder einmal hatte viele gespräche und
allerlei hektik im vorfeld des
parteitages gegeben
wieder einmal bemühten sich unsere
zahlreichen politischen gegner und
feinde
die gibt es auch und das totenglöcklein
läuten wieder einmal konfrontiert man
uns mit echt oder vorgeblich sinkenden
umfragewerten und wieder einmal erlebe
ich wie sich viele parteimitglieder
davon anstecken lassen
ein durchaus nachvollziehbarer sorge um
unsere parteien unser friedliches
projekt sind einige in schon fast
panikartigen reaktionen wieder einmal
das sage ich ihnen aber auch habe ich
mich und zwar mit erfolg bemüht mich von
alledem nicht anstecken zu lassen und
mir meine gelassenheit zu bewahren
und ich bin ja ich bin mir jetzt im
moment schon nicht mehr ganz zu beginn
wie es in der tat sehr wichtigen
parteitages sehr sicher dass ich in den
nächsten stunden und tagen ein weiteres
déjà vu erlebnis haben werde wenn man
sich nämlich die chronologie der
parteitage unserer ja noch recht jungen
partei anschaut das waren schon einige
dann waren sie meistens zwar erstens
nahezu alle von mehr oder minder großen
aufgeregtheiten im vorfeld geprägt
manche auch noch zu beginn der ganzen
geschichte
vor allem aber waren wie zweiten
vorangehenden aufgeregtheiten und
befindlichkeit zum trotz in ihren
schriftlichen ergebnis praktisch immer
zielführend und erfolgreich und ich gehe
felsenfest davon aus dass das auch bei
diesen kölner parteitag der fall sein
wird wenn damen und herren wir werden am
ende des morgigen tages nicht nur ein
hochkompetentes spitzenkandidaten team
haben das den kopf und die gesichter
unserer bundestagswahlkampfes bilden
wird wir werden auch neue richter und
erwerbs richter vom bundesgericht haben
vor allem aber werden wir in großer
eintracht ich prognostiziere dass ich
will mir sicher so wird es kommen in
großer eintracht ein überzeugendes
programm zur bundestagswahl
verabschiedet haben mit dem sich unsere
partei identifizieren können indem sie
sich wiederfinden und dem wir die bürger
mit gesundem menschenverstand da draußen
werden überzeugen können uns der
alternative für deutschland am 24
september ihre stimme zu geben
liebe freunde dafür sind wir hier nach
köln gekommen oder zum teil ja nicht
ganz einfachen bedingungen die eine oder
andere geschichte schon gehört da
draußen sind ziemlich viele unterwegs
die haben es nicht so mit demokratie und
dem journalismus der meinungen und die
versuchen uns daran zu hindern
für diesen freitag haben sich aber auch
und das soll bitte nicht unter den tisch
gekehrt werden hunderte von
parteimitgliedern und sehr viele von
denen sind heute hier in oft
aufopferungsvolle arbeit über viele
monate zum teil auch anderthalb jahre in
den zahlreichen ausschüssen engagiert
dafür haben wir alle beträchtliche
kosten amtseid und zum teil auch an geld
auf uns genommen und ich bin bereit
jedem im saal zu wetten
am sonntagabend werden wir es wieder mal
geschafft haben
ich muss ich muss dazu nicht einmal aber
ich muss trotzdem kurz den dem riesigen
rheinländer eigenen optimismus bemühen
aber vielleicht ist er ja auch ganz
hilfreich das rheinland rund um köln hat
nämlich ein eigenes grundgesetz das
wissen wahrscheinlich viele von ihnen
nicht oder in der region lebt weiß was
dieses rheinische grundgesetz besteht
aus sage und schreibe elf artikeln und
hier in dem zusammenhang artikel 3
grundgesetz zu zitieren das lautet so
knapp wie klar hätte noch immer jot
jejange
[Applaus]
ich kannte sich hat bayer in der stadt
hier gelebt und so liebe freunde ist es
uns jedes am ende dieses parteitages
sein
die parteifreunde da schreibt die
journalistin melanie amann nach langer
recherche ein ganzes buch über uns über
uns die alternative für deutschland das
unlängst erschienen ist und betitelt ist
allen ernst wird mit angst für
deutschland so etwas buch das er tätig
es wird darin wortreich in feluy er die
wähler seien angst bürger angst sei die
uns eine klammer das geht über viele
viele seiten die unsere partei zusammen
doch diese analyse ist ich sage es klar
und deutlich dieser analyse ist schlicht
falsch
meine damen und herren wer sich in
diesem land unter diesen bedingungen zum
beispiel denen da draußen vor diesem
prozess zur amb bekennt für wer für sie
kämpft und im kreisverband am
straßenstand oder wo auch immer politik
macht das eines ganz gewiss nicht sein
wenn ich ängstlich
werner für afg politiker wissen wir alle
die gewebe treiben die politik braucht
es mut manchmal sogar ziemlich viel
davon
und den haben wir auch liebe freunde
ohne mut geht das nicht was wir machen
gute politik wird aus dem mut gemacht
und nicht von angst und gute politik
machen wir bereits in elf landtagen
unseres vaterlandes und in wenigen
wochen wenn es 13 landtage sein und im
september machen wir gute und mutige
politik auch im deutschen bundestag
darum hier
[Musik]
ja ich weiß ich weiß durchaus auch in
unseren reihen gibt es einige notorische
nörgler und pessimisten gegenüber den ja
tatsächlich bestehenden
innerparteilichen streit was in panik
geraten und in jedem kleinen rückgang
von umfragewerten unserer partei gleich
ihren bevorstehenden niedergang
befürchten das sind die eher zaghaften
charaktere denen eine gewisse angst
womöglich tatsächlich nicht ganz fremd
ist die frage ich aber vor was habt ihr
eigentlich angst vor streit im ernst
angst vor streit wo würden wir denn
angekommen sein liebe freunde wenn wir
jeden streit vermeiden und womöglich
minutenlangen vorgestellten dauer
applaus wie duracell platten auf
cdu-parteitagen zelebrierten für eine
kanzlerin mit erbärmlichen reden
was für eine partei würden wir denn sein
wenn wir uns kandidaten oder vorsitzende
mit einer zustimmung von sage und
schreibe 100 fällen wie man es außer bei
der spd und dort für einen martin schulz
man stelle sich das vor
sonst sonst nur noch in nordkorea kind
nicht nicht einmal in der ddr war das
übliche hatten aber auch eine
schamgrenze der erich honecker der hat
99 78 prozent bei der spd sind auf 100%
kim jong chol willkommen in deutschland
aber wollen wir womöglich dahin ich
sagte ich jedenfalls nicht offener
diskurs ja auch streit gehört in einer
jungen und vitalen politischen parteien
noch nicht in apparatschik tun erstarrt
ist dazu da sein muss sogar sein ist
auch kein grund zur panik übrigens auch
dann nicht wenn dabei das eine oder
andere mal öffentlich wird geschadet hat
das wir machen natürlich vergessen wir
scheidet hat uns das noch nie
wenn es an die wahlen geht in einen
monat sind war soweit wenn es an die
wahlen geht dann muss der streit ruhen
dann müssen die reihen geschlossen sein
dann muss man in der tat gemeinsam in
den politischen kampf gegen die gegner
ziehen und dabei muss man auch
befindlichkeiten zurückzustellen bereit
sein und zwar täglich jeder von uns
[Applaus]
wert haben wir aber und das merkt meinen
optimismus noch immer geschafft
erfolgreicher übrigens als jede andere
neue partei in deutschland vor uns ich
frage mich manchmal warum sind wir so
können wir vielleicht auch noch unsere
erfolge sehen sagen wir eine partei die
das gebucht hat in deutschland nach vier
jahren ihrer existenz wir hier haben wir
werden keine finden
oder oder angst vor sinkenden
umfragewerten noch verrückter haben denn
die meinungsumfragen zum wahlverhalten
unsere partei betreffend je gestimmt
nahezu nie ich kenne nur eine ausnahme
fast immer sagen unsere tatsächlich
tatsächlichen wahlergebnisse zum teil
sogar sehr deutlich über den
umfragewerten
warum sollten wir also darauf schauen
wie das kaninchen auf die schlange warum
sollten wir das tun
umfragen sind keine wahlergebnisse und
es ist auch gar nicht so wichtig wo man
wenige monate vor einer wahl steht
entscheidend ist auf'm platz hatten
alter fußballtrainer mal gesagt das
führungsamt platz bis 24 erneut dass der
waldach das ergebnis fällt wo wir jetzt
in den umfragen stehen ist so
entscheidung nicht wollen wir am ende
womöglich manfred güllner vom institut
forsa etwa glauben schenken ja gehts
dennoch ich sage es mal salopp
[Applaus]
ich sag mal salopp wird mir schlecht
scheißegal was etwa ein album für die
manfred güllner von vor wäre sowieso
eine unseren untergang offizieren und
jetzt der umfrage werden
mir egal
deswegen egal weil ich weiß aus sauberen
analysen die wir haben dafür ein sehr
solides wählerpotenzial längst haben das
bundesweite starke regionale
differenzierungen enthält das aber bei
mindestens zehn prozent liegt und das
ist erst der anfang
zweiter zweitens kann ich eben den
unterschied zwischen umfragen und
wahlergebnissen nur zu gut dass ist zu
weiten teilen mit verlaub hochbezahlte
kaffeesatzleserei mit viel wunsch
potenzial kaum mehr als das und mich
ängstlich das nicht nein
ich jedenfalls habe keine angst und ich
sehe auch keinen grund dazu
ganz im gegenteil ich habe große
zuversicht insbesondere im hinblick auf
die bundestagswahl aber auch auf die
bevorstehenden landtagswahlen befreundet
auch allen grund dazu
und hier in köln fügen wir mit unserem
wahlprogramm das wird unsere hauptarbeit
er zum anschluss sein einen weiteren
sehr guten grund dazu ihr sehnsucht der
menschen in ihrem land mein gott die ist
doch für uns alle spürbar
ich weiß gar nicht wie oft ich dafür
auch im privaten kontext gesehen doch
der mensch nach einer echten einer
lebendigen und vitalen opposition im
parlament
die ist so riesengroß ist mit händen zu
greifen und das bewusstsein dafür dass
nur wir diese position in diesem land in
dieser zeit sein können
das ist auch jedermann klar das ist
unser potenzial und das liefern wir und
darum werden wir gewählt
[Applaus]
von natürlich transportiert und saß im
bundestag und zwar nicht um die fünf
prozent grenze oder sowas herum sondern
deutlich deutlich wer deutlich höher
also idee als kürzel für angst dva man
im sinne jetzt aber ganz sicher nicht
es bleibt dabei wir sind die alternative
für deutschland und zwar bis auf
weiteres ganz sicher die einzige wie
dieses land hat
[Applaus]
und weil wir alle werfen wissen dieses
wissen eins werden wir gemeinsam einen
fulminanten und erfolgreichen
bundestagswahlkampf veranstalten zudem
dieser parteitag den staatsschutz
liefert ein jeder von uns gehalten das
ihm mögliche dazu beizutragen
da dürfen keine eigenen karriere
ambitionen in eine rolle spielen ebenso
wenig übrigens wie persönliche
sympathien oder antipathien wir werden
nur dann richtig erfolgreich sein wenn
ein jeder sich selbst und sein manchmal
auch starkes ego zurückzunehmen und sich
in den dienst der gemeinsamen sache zu
stellen bereit ist
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich selbst zum beispiel darauf bin ich
gar keinen hehl machen ich hätte
durchaus gerne auch für den bundestag
kandidiert
ich konnte das aber für diese
bundestagswahl deswegen nicht tun weil
ich gegenüber meinem landesverband auf
meiner landtagsfraktion im wort stand
und weiter stehe und das bricht man
nicht einfach familiäre gründe kam bei
mir hinzu aber aber widmet das ist
überhaupt nicht schlimm weil wir uns als
einzelne nicht so wichtig nehmen sollten
mir wird da so nun verpflichtungen und
ich sage bewusst auch ehre zugleich sein
meinen einsatz für die partei und die
auf die landeslisten gewählten
exzellenten kandidaten zu erbringen und
intensiv und deutschlandweit im
wahlkampf für ein optimales ergebnis
unserer afd zu arbeiten
[Applaus]
wie viele viele tausend andere
parteimitglieder in den je eigenen
tätigkeitsfeldern auch wir sind eben und
das macht einen unterschied wir sind
eben keine partei von karteileichen
sondern eine echte graswurzelbewegung
mit medien die für ihre sache glühen und
die bereit sind dafür opfer zu bringen
sei schon opfer überhaupt hier
reinzukommen und darum
[Applaus]
mit
mit einer zornigen entschlossenheit
wieder setzen wir uns diesen
widerständen und darum fürchten uns
unsere müden politischen gegner so sehr
sie fürchten uns meine damen und herren
aus gutem grund angst also um daraus
zurückbekommen haben wir nicht weder in
dem was wir dazu noch guard leitmotiv
unserer politischen arbeit
was wir aber sehr wohl haben ist sorge
dass etwas anderes als angst sorge um
unser vaterland deutschland die geht
tief ist nur zu gegründet und die einst
tatsächlich jede sorge ist unsere
zentrale motivation
es ist ganz sicher kein zufall das ist
in unseren reihen eine besonders hohe
zahl an menschen mit in der regel
mehreren kindern gibt anders als etwa
bei den grünen wie kommt das nur daher
daher haben wir das was was
wissenschaftler etwas nicht saniert eine
hohe zukunft präferenz nennen man könnte
es auch einfacher ausdrücken und sagen
wir wollen unser land in einen guten
einen lebenswerten einem unserer kultur
gerecht werdenden zustand an die
kommenden generationen dass sie die
unsere kinder und enkel übergeben
eine angela merkel braucht das nicht
eine claudia roth auch nicht
einmal einmal anders gewendet man kann
leuten wie merkel und zu rücken und
viele vorwerfen aber eines ganz sicher
nicht nämlich dass sie keine nachhaltige
politik betreiben doch das tun sie liebe
freunde das tun sie seit vielen jahren
die betreibe seit vielen jahren merkel
von berlin aus schulz mit vor kurzem aus
brüssel eine politik zum sogar sehr
nachhaltigen schaden des deutschen
volkes
[Applaus]
die tour nicht in form einer absurden
migrationspolitik die letztlich gar
keine aktive und gestaltende politik ist
iris auch wie es ihre aufgabe wäre
sondern sogar das gegenteil von politik
in gestalt einer kopf- und hirnlosen
umwelt und energiepolitik in form einer
vermeintlichen euro rettungspolitik die
de facto eine gigantische umverteilung
von menschen die hart arbeiten zu
verantwortungslos agierenden menschen
ist die 100 die 100 in gestalt multipler
recht welche die sie nicht weiter
kümmern ich brauche das eigentlich unter
uns nicht weiter auszuführen wie alle
kennen das
es ist das was uns eins wir kennen das
alle zur genüge so also wie
nachhaltigkeit marke merkel unschuld in
diesem land aus liebe freunde da sind
unsere gegner da sind unsere gegner
deren agieren wir so entschlossen
bekämpfen müssen die mir mancher kampf
in den eigenen reihen zuweilen geführt
zu werden scheint
ich sag mal ich sage mal ganz ehrlich
und bescheiden ich habe manches lernen
und verstehen müssen so zum beispiel in
welch ungeheure gefahr
diese komplett verantwortungslosen
deutschland abschafft für unser land
bringen bzw
bereits geschafft habe ich habe das
anfangs gar nicht so anstellen gehabt
ich habe das begreifen müssen
ich habe dass ich gebe es zu zunächst
einmal gar nicht vollständig erkannt
gerade in jüngerer zeit habe gehe ich
sehr bewusst durch die straßen meines
landes und meiner stadt
und wenn ich an einem samstagmittag im
zentrum meiner stadt unterwegs bin mit
offenen augen und ich gucke hin müssen
sie was ich dann sehe ich wirklich ohne
jede übertreibung aber mit grossem mehr
strecken
ich sehe noch vereinzelt deutsche
[Applaus]
und wenn ich und wenn ich darüber
erschrecke nicht ob irgendeine
ausländerfeindlichkeit ich mir völlig
fremd ist sondern weil dieses ungeheure
maß an wie auch immer in unser land
gekommene migranten offensichtlich mehr
hat sich aus anderen kulturkreisen
stammt mein land mainland zwangsläufig
und unwiderruflich in ein ganz anderes
verwandelt das kaum mehr etwas mit dem
land zu tun hat in dem ich groß geworden
bin und wenn einer
[Applaus]
und wenn eines meiner kinder einer
meiner söhne inzwischen fest in
melbourne lebend in australien mir sagt
um 33 morgen übrigens wieder geschrieben
hat dass und warum er trotz seines
ausgeprägten familien sind ganz sicher
nie mehr nach deutschland zurückkommt
bei der dieses land aus gründen den ich
nichts mehr entgegensetzen kann am
abgrund sieht dann bin ich für die leute
da draußen die da demonstrieren und für
unsere ganzen politischen gegner die
augen vor alledem entweder verschließen
oder die das sogar propagieren die linke
grüne und teile der spd
da bin ich für diese leute also ein
ausländerfeind ein rassist k nein meine
freunde das bin ich ganz sicher nicht
nicht einmal ansatzweise das bin ich nie
gewesen und werde ich ab und an meiner
überzeugung niemals sein ebenso wenig
wie die irgendjemand in diesen salat ist
wir sind wissen sie wissen sie wir sind
nur elementare vernünftig dafür werden
wir beschimpft und wenn wir elementar
vernünftig sind dann sehen was hier
geschieht
und ich weiß meine tiefe sorge und nicht
etwa plumpe angst um meine tiefe sorge
sehr präzise sogar in zahlen zu
begründen
wir wollen nicht zum minderheit im
eigenen land werden und sind doch für
teilen bereit
ich lebe ich nehme nur ganz kurz in
bezug auf die wahl in der türkei
effektive auch in unserem land der hier
lebenden türken vom vergangenen sonntag
dass die eindeutige mehrheit etwa der
hier lebenden türken nicht etwa allen
einer keineswegs da muss man
differenzieren aber die ganz eindeutige
mehrheit keine freunde der
freiheitlichen gesellschaft sind während
sie legen sie gleichwohl nur zu gerne
für sich in anspruch nehmen das haben
wir spätestens bei dem vergangenen
sonntag sogar schriftlich
zwei drittel fast zwei drittel der hier
lebenden türken mit wahlberechtigung
haben bei den türkischen verpackungs
rentner referendum mit ja gestimmt
gehen wir davon aus dass mal nebenher
das wohl nahezu alle aleviten und kursen
unter ihnen gern sicher mit nein
gestimmt haben dürften findet sogar
deutlich über 80 prozent
was hier was hier auf dem spiel steht
liebe parteifreunde ist nicht weniger
als unsere freiheitliche gesellschaft im
ganzen und wenn wir den hebel nicht
jetzt und sehr entschlossen umlegen
dann ist die unwiderrufliche veränderung
unserer heimat in einen ihm gar nicht so
vielen jahren muslimisch geprägtes land
eine mathematische gewissheit
[Applaus]
mir drängt sich da drängt sich da
manchmal der vergleich vom untergang der
titanic auf alle sind doch froh gelaunt
es ist eine entspannte partystimmung auf
entdeckt wie unter den abc notwendige
kurskorrektur auf dem riesigen schiff
ist schon kaum mehr machbar
die kollision mit einem eisberg ist
nicht was man sich vorstellen kann oder
will
dabei ist sie bereits unvermeidbar wem
das zu düster ist ich weiß nicht sicher
ob die entwicklung bereits unumkehrbar
ist wir alle wissen dass nicht wo der
exakt der point of no return ist gerade
deshalb aber sage ich ja ich rufe es so
laut ich es nur kann dieses land
deutschland ist unser land
es ist das land unserer großeltern und
eltern unsere bürgerpflicht ist aber
dass das land unserer kinder und enkel
sein zu lassen
nicht mehr lange versprochen aber einige
ganz kurz bemerkungen hinzufügen klingt
kriegerischen soll nicht falsch
verstanden werden
dazu müssen wir uns unser land
inzwischen schon zurück erobern und
damit meine ich wild entschlossen aber
friedlich kämpferisch aber mit
demokratischen rechtsstaatlichen mitteln
mit ganzem herzen aber auch mit klugheit
und klarem verstand die menschen sollen
spüren und wissen wir wer hier die afg
wir sind die die deutschland nicht
abschaffen wollen und unsere politischen
konkurrenten soll das bitter zu spüren
bekommen wir sind die die deutschland
nicht preisgeben werden meine damen und
herren
gut
diesen müssen wir gemeinsam stehen egal
wie stark der widerstand ist wir dürfen
wir dürfen da nicht weichen auch wenn
das schwerfällt und manchmal wehtut und
dieses kleine ganz gewiss nicht spaltet
die kleine ganz gewissen spalterisch
gemeinte nebenbemerkung gestatten sie
mir bitte auch wir müssen da restlos
geschlossen stehen debatten über einen
vermeintlichen realpolitischen und einen
vermeintlichen fundamental
oppositionellen flüge aus meiner sicht
eine trügerische wahrnehmung helfen uns
da kein jota weit noch
[Applaus]
platten ganz einfach lassen wir das ich
bitte sie wirklich alle
sie haben so viel was uns ein unsere
gegner stehen draußen und wir richten
unser geliebtes vaterland jawohl
vaterland den wir sind patrioten schritt
für schritt eine geradezu perfide weise
zu grunde
wir heißen merkel schulz maß stegner
roth göring eckardt und so weiter sie
öffnen die grenzen widerrechtlich für
jedermann frau merkel oder wir reden uns
einen die vermeintlichen flüchtlinge
seien für unser land und wertvoller als
gold so herr schulz der zugleich unser
gold auf europäischem altar
verschleudert oder wir bräuchten auch
zuwanderer die sich in unseren
sozialsystemen wohl und zu hause fühlen
so frau göring eckardt von den grünen
das muss man sich mal reinziehen oder
sie laufen wie die amtierende
vizepräsident des deutschen bundestages
claudia roth anständig diese schande für
unser land einmal vor in einem
demonstrationszug mit der deutschland
verrecke scania das ist eine schande
bedeutet
[Musik]
stockum kursraum oder ich komme zum
schluss
es wird wirklich allerhöchste zeit dass
die schon länger hier lebenden die schon
länger hier regierenden aus ihren ämtern
im dienste des deutschen volke
verabschieden und das nachhaltig liebe
freunde
[Applaus]
sprechen kann
im sinne einer minute
nein
bis 20
ich bitte sie das ganz gut und da mach
ich schluss ich habe lange geredet ja
wir können diese gestalten nicht mehr
ertragen und nein das ist keineswegs
fundamental opposition sondern ja das
ist die liebe zu unserer heimat und
unserem vaterland und nein
und daran keinen zweifel gelassen mit
diesen figuren werden wir keine
koalition eingehen
[Applaus]
und ja und ja wir werden auf diese weise
der verantwortung für unser land sehr
wohl gerecht und zwar als bärenstarke
oppositionspartei wurden sie bereits in
den ländern und schließlich nein das ist
keineswegs mangel der realpolitik
sondern es ist das kluge und notwendige
zu warten bis unsere position unter tut
sich was endgültig mehrheitsfähig sein
werden
liebe freunde so machen wir das so nicht
anders und auf ihrem parteitag in köln
fällt der startschuss dazu glück auf
deutschland glück auf
vielen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
mitarbeitende weiter